[Applaus]
solch einen auftritt haben selbst die
sicherheitsleute bei der gamescom noch
nicht der größte streaming hält derzeit
scheint montana black zu sein der den
trubel um seine person selbst auf
instagram gepostet hat tausende
schreiende kreischende fans haben ihn
bei der spielemesse in köln begrüßt
nachdem er einige tage zuvor angekündigt
hatte dort vorbeizuschauen
am morgen schaut ja noch aus seinem
hotelzimmer auf die besucher die in
richtung messegelände laufen einzelne
winken ihm sogar zu
dann schließlich macht er sich selbst
auf den weg begleitet von seinem kumpel
marc gebauer sowohl auf der live
streaming plattform twitch wie auch bei
youtube ist der 34 jährige ein megastar
ob call of duty fifa oder fortnight
seine videos bringen die fans vor die
bildschirme und im wahren leben zucker
zum ausrasten auf einer messe
die erfolgreichen streamer haben also
schon einige zeit rockstar status
erlangt und montana black ist einer der
ganz großen in diesem metier er selbst
freut sich übrigens mal ohne schutz dorn
es in die twitter trends geschafft zu
haben
[Applaus]